hello and welcome to this video yeah in
this video I'm going to tell you what's
going on in the next couple of weeks
because I haven't done much on the
channel because I was extremely busy
writing recording yeah doing support on
chasuble many things were going on and
this leads to a couple of products
coming coming up or yeah think's getting
released so what do I want to talk about
in this video first of all there has
been released 12 days ago of a black
repertoire the lifetime repertoire on
the nimzo-indian and Rogozin a
cooperation between film acid daniel
bearish and myself it yeah it's only now
for 12 days and we already have more
than 500 happy students of this
repertoire the reason why I want to
mention it again is that there is an
introductory sale for this product and
this is going to end you see the counter
here it's going to end in one day ten
hours from this recording time so from
the time is this video is released
you've got about a day a little bit more
but still benefit from the reduced
introductory offer um so it's just 20 US
dollars instead of 30 or 85 with video
instead of 160 so it's a pretty steep
discount um also I don't think it will
be on sale all that soon again there we
have sales usually forum Black Friday
but I'm not sure that that is going to
be on sale again I'm that shortly
afterwards I mean I'm not responsible
for everything and that regard but yeah
if you are interested in a black defense
against 1d for its a full repertoire
based on the names and logos and it also
has the Catalan and offbeat East rise um
it's a good thing to go for this now as
you can save quite a bit of money um
also a good thing to mention is that on
Chesterville all those repertoires are
not set in stone but rather support it
and
yeah improved all the time based on user
feedback we recognized that for example
the coverage of some variations was to
light them there was a need for more
variation than these are currently edit
so we have a product that is going to be
improved over time so this is a bit of
an urgent thing because if you want to
get it at the better price like one day
about some hours time left to do so the
other thing is I want to announce and I
mentioned this on and off in some some
cases what the next thing is going to be
we've got one more thing ok and this is
going to be me and then following I'm
going to switch to a board now there is
a course coming up and it's going to be
released on November 11th at 11.11
a.m. Central Europe in time so it's easy
to set this into your calendars if you
are interested in the whole subject in
the first place so we are going to
release a full black record black group
black repertoire on jazz over based on
the Sicilian specially covers the
mainline and it's called fight like
Magnus the Sicilian because magnus
carlsen has one year go started to play
this opening again he did so earlier in
his career in the world championship
match against Haryana Khurana and did so
with excellent success in the course of
this year as you probably know Magnus
hasn't lost the tournament game a
classical time control game for now I
think 101 games or something and it
means he has never lost with this new
for him or refreshed black repertoire as
well um so this repertoire will be a
full repertoire based on the Sicilian
defense and I'm going to show you some
things that it does include so that you
get an idea what what is all about um we
have asked the backbone every Sicilian
repertoire needs the open Sicilians as a
backbone we have them specially cough so
I'm going to also play this move water
there are another way to go to the
special
but Magnus always press 96 and the
sveshnikov is this variation and this is
I think one of them let's say it's a bit
of difficult to to to coin there but I
think in if you compare it to other
Sicilians there is one really really
great asset of this opening or advantage
of this opening you with black very
rarely getting attacked on the King your
king is always going to be rather safe
and the dynamic possibilities are often
more on the black side and then on the
white side this is a difference to many
other Sicilian variations where black is
sometimes getting strategic advantages
but it's attacked on the King that's
very typical or the dragon denied or for
some other variations in the specially
coffee and the play is decidedly
different this is mostly because black
early on gets a pawn to e5 and that's a
tiny different structure in many other
variations wide manages to push the a
pawn to e5 for example one get an early
King side attack going with g4 g5 this
is never happening in this version cough
um in this version in coffee M you have
many fascinating and very very sharp
lines for example yeah this is the
continuation if you look at lines like
that
there are some amazingly attractive
lines that you can go into for example
if they take and you get this double
pawn
you get to play f5 very early on to
attack the white center like has really
great dynamic game and that has been yea
proven over the last I'd say forty years
since the special cough has been kind of
reinvented by especially cough and some
other players from the chair been scary
and sometimes called the chelyabinsk
wary ation so I think this is a very
attractive variation and Magnus has done
very well actually kawana never played
into this variation karana tried to move
Knight to d5 this is currently having a
bit of a revival on the top level mostly
because the traditional main lines like
over here or 95 verses which is a bit of
more of a strategic choice these are
considered to be totally fine for black
and therefore Khurana kind of unearthed
this 95 idea to set some fresher
problems
but here again the play is very
interesting here quite often you get a
position like that where later Bishop e7
and f5 leads to an attack on the
kingside because black has a pawn
majority them so for the open Sicilian
we have this vesnik off a very
attractive opening I always like to play
it I played it a bit under um and in the
late 1990s early 2000s before I somehow
got to play e5 but I'm getting
definitely going to play this version
come again and I tried but I didn't get
get into opportunity people played
anti-science against me which gets me to
the next point and it's not all the time
that you actually see that people play
their open Sicilian it opens a Syrian is
tricky there are so many lines and you
will experience if you actually get here
the starting point of this version cough
that many Club players won't even go to
b5 they play Knight f3
9b3 and this is really great because
black in most of these lines actually
even better very difficult to handle all
the opens a science so many people go to
play non main lines and of course we
have to deal with Bishop to b5 the
rosolie more variation after which I
will suggest to move g6 this is what
Magnus has played most often and this is
also leading to interesting struggles
quite often you will get a structure
like this I'm just going to put the
first couple of moves on the board where
you play e5 later and set up this
confirmation the e5 c5 information and
this is often called the pod vinik
formation I mean this name is already
taken their firm if it wasn't you might
as well call it the cards information
because pre plays it a lot throughout
this repertoire blue have this poor
information very frequently and the
reasoning behind this is that black is
putting those two pawns in the center
and controls d4 as much as possible and
this means the center will be closed and
this gives us more opportunities to play
on the flanks in particular the move f5
candy - really fascinating complications
yeah I'm very often we will play f5
sometimes f4 and go for an attack very
interesting and fascinating
possibilities so this is something that
and will definitely happen people play
Bishop b5 quite often nowadays because
they fear the open Sicilian is a bit too
much similarly people try this move for
example and that has been tried in a
recent game against me when I suggest a
5 as Magnus almost always plays again
setting up this center formation the
idea later is to play a5 and get an
attack on the kingside this is a common
scenario that we later attack with f5 um
line that also needs to be covered and I
have to say it's a full repertoire a
full sicilian repertoire we will also
look at 9 Slyke c3 that can happen here
or me
also on move to happens more frequently
on move to after which Magnus place
Knight f6 and this is also what I'm
recommend in the course and what I'm
doing is I'm basically following his his
variation choice sometimes he has played
two or three lines when I had to pick
one usually I picked the most recent
choice or the one that felt like he may
he means it like in the most serious way
like the plate of certain line in
classical five times and three times and
blitz I would take the one he chose for
classical um in some cases I feel um I
can improve on his plate it's possible
of course Magnus is the far better
player but if you for example take a
blitz game where you played a move on
and I move 12 and the computer and you
know all the indications that I have
show that different move is better I'm
going to choose that if it is really
clearly better than the one that he
played um so against the auto pin we
have ninety f6 and this is what he
usually plays um yeah what you get on
the club level quite often will be
Knight c3 by the way it's also covered
we play knight c6 and whenever possible
I'm trying to play again an e5 based
formation this can happen for example if
white plays g3 like this kind of close
caesarean and then I'm going to
recommend to play with E 5 and set up a
familiar pawn structure this is what
Magnus plays a lot as mentioned c5 if I
have been whenever possible I try to go
into that direction
the same thing applies for example if
white plays a variation like like this
yeah you can play e5 g6 Bishop g7 and
I'm going to do that so we have familiar
patterns and structures as far as
possible um of course in the Sicilian
right um can play all kinds of side
lines and we also cover those together
the somewhat odd moves like f4 or
whatever g3 this
is not theoretically super relevant but
might happen in your games so it's a
full repertoire it's meant to be
um yeah to fight really fight for a win
and this is some I think um with a
Sicilian defense is the best possible
way to do so because you have a let's
say yeah it built in non symmetrical
pawn structure it's very rare that you
have a yeah
get it getting to a dull position really
sometimes the lines and the sharper
lines can end up in crazy drawers like
in 20 something moves but this is just
what what happens if it's super
complicated sometimes so I'm looking
forward to present this repertoire we
will have chasuble coverage like in the
normal like interactive move trainer
course and of course video it will also
feature yeah sample games some some of
Magnus's games to illustrate the points
and maybe also strategic overview it's
say it's tough here we have only have
like two weeks until the release and
yeah it's almost completed but I'm still
working on it so it's um not not already
a completely finished product and the
final thing I'd like to mention what is
coming up and also something that I know
many people are looking forward to of
course in June or any June released keep
it simple one d4 on chesil and its
nearing 1000 students already it's a
great success and has been received very
positively and for this we're going to
change the picture a little bit there
will also be a print book yeah it's um
again released by a new in chess and
this is indeed a finished product from
my end I have submitted the the text and
everything and I heard from you in chess
that they are almost done on their part
if you look at the home page of new in
chess it says expected in October and
November
we're in October oh no that won't work
and very likely
it will be November late November maybe
early December somewhere like that it
might be that it so be in the November I
think the US takes a little bit longer
always um but this is what what will
happen um it's not entirely so entirely
um not something that I can influence if
they take longer it's not not my call
everything when my aunt has been done
but then they said that late November
early December is a reasonable time so
it's so before Christmas or if you want
a print book here on your under your
Christmas tree it will it will happen so
many things to look forward to I hope
you enjoyed the overview and I'm keep
you posted if new things happen also I'd
like to say that once this is done and
that is mid-november when the Sicilian
has been released
I will unfurl II think about what to do
with the channel I'm definitely not
closing it but currently it's pretty
dormant and should something should be
happening but I'm not entirely sure yet
what's kind of thing I will do with it
yeah if I do instructional videos or
again blitz games or whatever I'm
thinking about it it's a bit difficult
simply choose your time constraints I'm
heavily involved with writing and
everything and I completely enjoy it so
it's something that I love to do and I
have to see that everything can kind of
fit into a schedule that is manageable
all right thanks a lot for watching I'll
keep you posted
bye-bye